Hello Freak bitches.
It's societal standards and culture is a
big part of the way people decide what's
acceptable,
what's not acceptable.
So to these people.
I think for us growing up in America,
it's almost impossible to understand
what it would be like to be living in
like one of the most radicalized parts
of the world can understand the radical
behavior,
which is why I have no problem saying
that a guy who went and did nothing but
became radicalized,
like to me that's,
that's a mathematical equation right
there.
Like it's a,
you know,
it's a hard one because you know,
people still say to this day and age
like,
you know,
you shouldn't,
you shouldn't kill,
right.
We need to.
The counter insurgency strategy is based
off winning the hearts and minds of the
people that were going into countries
that we're going into.
And I think the only way that I can
describe it that makes sense to people
where that might at least allow them to
think outside of the education aspect.
Is that,
and you kind of,
you,
you alluded to the point a little bit,
but I mean you have daughters,
right?
Do you love your daughters?
Yeah.
Like how much though?
Like articulate for me how much you
love.
It's impossible for anybody to ever
express it in a way that someone who
doesn't have daughters would ever
understand or sons or children.
Totally and so love is a good analogy
because if you can understand how hard
it is to articulate that,
then you understand that there's another
side of that coin and that there's a
community of people somewhere in earth
that hates you to the exact same degree
that you love your children and can't
articulate and would do everything they
fucking can to end our way of life
because we let women go outside and have
their skin exposed.
You can say what you want.
You can think what you want and what's
the solution to solve that.
It's not books.
There's not a single.
I could.
I could put you in captivity for 14
years.
Joe and I could never convince you not
to love your daughters,
right?
Yeah,
but it's not our job to change,
but what I'm saying,
but hold on little whatever.
So what I'm saying is though is that
people think that there's just like,
oh,
you don't have to go over there and you
don't have to fight.
Well fuck that.
At some point you have to stand up for
what you believe in.
Right?
And when it comes to those people that
hate you as much as you love your kids,
again,
there's a small segment of that that you
could probably turn with books in
captivity,
right?
Which is what's happening to the guys
who get radicalized and get mo,
but for the other segment that would
like nothing more than to end your life
and everything you believe in.
What's the solution?
It's not fucking books.
You know?
What is the solution to try to turn a
guy around?
Once they've reached that level of
radicalization,
he can't.
So you either have to find something or
believe in something to the point that
you're willing to fight for it because
here's the deal,
we're x people and then there's white
people and regardless of what your x is,
your Christian Catholic,
whatever your next person,
there's somebody as a white person,
x and y people are going to fight.
If you believe in what you believe
enough,
then to protect that at some point
you're going to have to go beyond the
educational aspect of that.
And then by the time the podcast art.
So what's up man?
You
know,
you learn,
you learn a lot about yourself,
like I'm listening to you,
listen to your own podcast.
I listened to the good one.
I don't at all.
I can't,
I can't stand this.
I have no desire to listen to myself.
The only time is when I'm going through
mastering the system,
my tutorial,
I do sit there and I am interested in
how I'm teaching and what I said and how
I could have made the point clear in my
teaching.
So I,
I,
uh,
that's the only time but when it's a
podcast and I'm not talking about you
did sit,
I'm just talking about like,
just bullshit.
I don't want to hear myself.
It's good to hear though.
But for the same reason like you realize
why you're annoying to you.
Like I've,
I've found things that I,
I didn't know I did like little little
ticks,
little weird things like people do like
a big one is saying like people,
like there's like Tom said,
girl,
I love them to death but that mother
fucker out likes me.
He hurts me sometimes.
Like there's like a way,
like if you got like a guy like in his,
like a way like oh did he say that?
Or everybody does.
And when you guys are telling a story,
it's hilarious.
And he's like,
she came up to me and started mad
dogging me and I was like,
what the fuck you looking at?
I paid for all that shit.
And you didn't say none of that.
You just said I was like that.
I had that look on my right but I didn't
say shit.
And if you don't question,
did you actually say that you're like,
no,
I was not.
I was.
I was thinking
too.
You would have made it seem like a bad
motherfucker in this story.
In reality,
you didn't say shit.
I was like,
fuck you for that shit.
You said that.
No,
I thought it.
Fuck you.
And all.
And where you came from pitch.
Did you actually say to them?
No.
Oh man,
I hate that.
Another one that I.